are you kidding me this is the moment to
debate new regulations that have nothing
whatsoever to do with this crisis that's
what they're up to over there American
people need to know it Democrats won't
let us fund hospitals or saves small
businesses unless they get to dust off
the green New Deal I'd like to see
dimmer Senate Democrats tell new york
city doctors and nurses who are
literally over on as we speak that
they're filibustering hospital funding
and more masks because they want to
argue with the airlines over their
carbon footprint I'd like to see Senate
Democrats tell small business employees
in their states who are literally being
laid off every day that they're
filibustering relief that will keep
people on the payroll because Democrats
special interest friends want to squeeze
employers while they're vulnerable
squeeze these employers while they're
vulnerable
I'd like to see Senate Democrats tell
all American seniors who've seen their
hard-earned retirement savings that
literally melt away as the markets track
toward their worst months since 1931
that they're continuing to hold up
emergency measures over tax credits for
solar panels tax credits for solar
panels even with the Federal Reserve
announcing even further extraordinary
steps today the markets are tanking once
again as I said because this body can't
get its act together and the only reason
can't get his act together is right over
here on the other side of the aisle so
these are just a few of the completely
non-germane wishlist items if they're
rallying behind preventing us from
getting this emergency relief to the
American people right now
eleventh-hour demand the democrats would
decide are more important than Americans
paychecks and the personal safety of
doctors and nurses so remember what one
of speaker Pelosi top lieutenants in the
house said in just a few days ago and
this is a direct quote this is a
tremendous opportunity to restrict
things to fit our vision to fit our
vision that was the Democratic whip in
the house just laying it out there
reminds me of the definition of
Washington gap when a politician in
Washington tells you what he really
means and we heard something similar
here on the Senate floor last night just
last night here was one of our
Democratic colleagues quote how many
times are we going to get a shot at a 1
trillion dollar-plus program right here
on the floor last night I don't know how
many trillion plus packages we're gonna
have in other words let's don't waste
this opportunity to take full advantage
and get our whole wish list done they
ought to be embarrassed mr. president
in fact I've heard from some of them who
are embarrassed talking like this is
some juicy political opportunity this is
not a juicy political opportunity this
is a national emergency we had days of
productive bipartisan talks to get to
this point Senate Democrats that Dallas
Senate Republicans and negotiated
furiously to get to this point the bill
now contains a huge number of changes
that our Democratic colleagues requested
including major changes we were this
close this flows in yesterday morning
Speaker of the House flew back from San
Francisco and suddenly the Senate
serious bipartisan process turned into
this left wing episode of
supermarket sweep unrelated issues left
and right I'll tell you what a really
lower our carbon footprint mr. president
if the entire economy continues to
crumble with hundreds of thousands more
Americans laid out because Senate
Democrats won't let us act at all or our
carbon footprint all right every single
American outside of Washington knows
this is no time for this nonsense a
surgeon in Fresno California says quote
we're at war with no ammo we are at war
with no ammo
that's a surgeon in Fresno an intensive
care nurse in New York City says if we
don't get the proper equipment soon we
are going to get sick Democrats are
filibustering more mass and aid for
hospitals every day more Americans wake
up to the news that their jobs are gone
their jobs are gone Democrats are
filibustering programs to keep people on
the payroll and they're filibustering a
huge expansion of unemployment insurance
which they themselves negotiated and put
into the bill hundreds of dollars extra
per week for laid off workers on top of
existing unemployment benefits and
Democrats are blocking it this has got
to stop and today's the day it has to
stop the country is out of time out of
town when the Democratic House passed
their phase two bill even though Senate
Republicans would have written it very
differently we sped it through the
Senate and passed it quickly without
even amending it I literally told my
colleagues dig and vote for it
for the sake of building bipartisan
momentum because Republicans understand
that of national crisis calls for
urgency and it calls for bipartisanship
it's time for that good faith to be
reciprocated it's time for Democrats to
stop playing politics and step up to the
plate the small businesses in their own
states deserve it their own state's
emergency room doctors deserve it their
own constituents who've lost their jobs
deserve it in my home state of Kentucky
the governor has effectively paused
commerce across the state and our
unemployment system crashed due to
demand Kentuckians need help now and we
aren't alone I've heard the pleas from
health care workers in New York and
Seattle I've listened to the small
business owners crying out in Brooklyn
and Chicago why does only one side
understand that this is urgent why are
these hard-hit cities our own senators
are happy really to keep this
slow-walking going on indefinitely is
that really something these folks on the
other side are comfortable with and
definitely slow walking all of those I
couldn't have the Senate not rise to the
occasion at a time when everybody else
in the country is pulling together
they're pulling us apart the examples
are all over the country that we ought
to look to health care heroes to
neighborhood volunteers tonight
industries everybody is unifying and
pitching in what about here in the
Senate time to get with the program it's
your time to pass historic or leave that
we have built together country doesn't
have time for these political games they
need progress so we're going to vote in
just a few minutes and I assure you mr.
president the American people will be
watching